I'm Russell Brauer and I'm director of
audio and the lead composer of Blizzard
Entertainment as audio director of
Blizzard my job is to first and foremost
help create an environment where this
wonderful staff that I have the great
honor of working with feel safe to be
creative and do everything it takes to
affect the sound of everything we do so
every sound that Blizzard makes whether
it's in the game whether it's on the web
with a cinematic if it makes sound we
have something to do with so my job is
to kind of keep the Train on the rails
and occasionally lead by example in my
case I do write music as well the advice
I would give to someone who's just
starting out relates to that finding
your passion statement I was lucky
enough to find out at a relatively young
age what I really love to do and in this
case for me it was music and sound and
in finding that I found the thing that I
would I would go home every night if I
had a day job or whatever I would go
home every night to my studio and create
music and sound just because I had to it
was burning a hole in my belly and I and
so I tell people you need to want it
that much that you would do it any way
that you would do it if you had no job
you'd still do it if you had to pay
because it's a student film maybe that
you're scoring or a student video game
like you would have these days you would
just do it for free or even pay to do it
you might have to pay the musicians out
of your own pocket if you as a person
getting started out can can hear me say
all that and said yes that's me I can do
that
I'll stay glued to it then you probably
have a chance if you get to do what you
love it's there's just nothing better I
mean there's no better way to enjoy
your your passion and to contribute and
to leave something in this world better
than you found it leave some art behind
leave some you beautiful music whatever
it is that's the best thing you can do
and so if you if you've got the
perseverance for it please go for it at
Blizzard we're known for three major
franchises the Warcraft franchise
specifically now World of Warcraft the
Diablo franchise and Starcraft and they
are very different from each other and
even though it's the same group of
people of us we number about 40 strong
now in the sound Department it's a very
big responsibility to maintain the
individual identity of each of these
franchises we even record the different
franchises with different orchestras in
different size rooms in very specific
places Warcraft has a kind of Bronze Age
sound so we record that in a in an old
church chapel if you will with a six
60-foot ceiling and it just has this
sound that's very specific and with
Diablo we've relied heavily on choral
music and we had a specific choir for
the demonic side and another one for the
heavenly side Diablos are really unique
franchise for us in that the music is
very iconic for a lot of our fans and
players Diablo was the first thing we
ever played in fact I was the first game
I ever played
long before I ever knew I would work at
Blizzard the soundtrack that Matt Ullman
created for Diablo 1 Diablo 2 and the
expansion for Diablo 2 is it's unusual
it's something that you wouldn't expect
it's 12 string guitar through a delay
and it has these iconic chords and it it
doesn't make intuitive sense but it
completely works and that became
ingrained and in the hearts and memories
of everyone who loved the game Matt had
started experimenting with more live
orchestras and this vog marryin sound so
we picked up that thread
and ran with it and went with this very
large orchestra sound in fact we
recorded the orchestra in a the most
old-fashioned concert hall we could like
the oldest way you can hear music short
of being in an amphitheater is in this
big hall and then we added this choral
element again with this Irish choir a
nuna which is a very gorgeous sound for
the quote-unquote hell choir and then
playing against type this all-male just
nasty sounding choir for the heaven side
and that sort of support the story ideas
that maybe the evil sides a little more
seductive and beautiful and heaven has
in fighting going on there's turmoil
going on and so much so that Diablo
could walk in through the side door and
start kicking the tar out of everybody
so in the end we're storytellers
everyone at Blizzard is a storyteller no
matter what their discipline and the
things I just mentioned are some of the
devices we used as sound and music folks
to to help tell that story I think sound
music especially is a game of contrasts
so the epic moments are more epic if you
have either quiet moments or moments of
silence our goal is for people to feel
immersed and hopefully keep the sound
turned off I've been fortunate enough my
career to work in just about every
medium there is television a little film
not a lot but a little toys and a lot of
theme parks as well as games and there's
a common thread storytelling a
storytelling and a linear medium like
film or television is really important
because you do learn a lot about what I
mentioned earlier about contrasts or
setting up a moment and then paying it
off and learning something about pacing
and how to work with timing to picture
and things like that these are all
skills that are really great to have
because in a video game
well usually something can happen at the
most unexpected time you still have
these opportunities to tell a mini story
through sound with a series of like
sonic events that aren't just randomly
put together in a hodgepodge but
literally have some deliberate pacing to
them so designing sound for a theme park
is really a lot like designing sound for
world of warcraft I think of all the
warcraft is a theme park in a box but
I'd have to say technology is a
double-edged sword because the fact that
we could now play a hundred two hundred
three hundred a thousand sounds at once
isn't necessarily a good thing one of
the reasons people to this day still
love the music from the old oldest video
games Mario or what-have-you is because
the technology was so limited they had
to make the melody count with only one
note playing at a time or maybe two or
four so the melodies had to be good and
be memorable and so again using music as
an example the best music would sound
just as powerful on a music box as it
would with a symphony orchestra so a lot
of what we're doing these days is making
sure that we don't just use the
technology for its own sake I think one
of the big frontiers ahead is simulating
what mixers do when they dub a movie
they have every voice every sound effect
every piece of music on a different
volume control or fader and
scene-by-scene they decide what's
important and what moves the the story
forward and turn off the rest so I think
the big it's both a boon and a challenge
that we can play all the sounds we want
it's all very clean but now the
challenge is to use great responsibility
to not to not overdo it